recently as I was watching a Shark Tank
episode I saw a new segway type product
made by zoom technologies these are two
individual units that correlate with
each foot unfortunately they didn't get
a deal but this made me think about what
happened to segways there was so much
hype around them a couple of years ago
but now they are nowhere to be seen and
with the quick search on Google Trends
revealed the same information Segway
peaked in November of 2015 and today
they only bring in 21 percent of that
traffic so here's what happened to
Segway first of all Segway didn't
fulfill a specific purpose or fix a
specific problem
it was simply advertised as a generic
alternative to walking and to make
things worse it wasn't very good at
replacing walking as using a Segway was
more of a hassle in a lot of places a
Segway can't be used due to
infrastructure issues like potholes or
uneven pavement so as a replacement for
walking segways definitely didn't make
sense furthermore in certain places
where segways actually did make some
sense Segway did market it very well
many companies actually gave us a
greater shot for example the USPS tested
them for letter carriers police tested
in Chicago and even gas companies used
them but Segway really never catered to
one of these categories and convinced
any of these niches why Segway was the
way station continued to go so in the
end they weren't solving a problem that
people needed to be fixed so many people
who may have been interested were never
actually reached and a lot of people who
did get it never used it on a regular
basis as it served no real purpose
moving on another huge hindrance to
segways growth was its price even today
the cheapest Segway is in 90s which
costs almost five hundred dollars back
then segways costs well into thousands
of dollars considering these high prices
these just didn't make sense for the
average person to pay for to get a
not-so-good alternative to walking a
nice bike or skateboard could be had for
well less than half the price of a
Segway now of course there are
boosted boards which are as expensive or
oftentimes even more expensive than
segways but these were much more
versatile as well you could simply pick
it up and carry it if you were going to
a grocery store you can carry in your
backpack if you're traveling but you
would not have a very good experience
trying to take a Segway with you good
luck hauling around a 90 to 120 pound
contraption with you now only were stuck
was expensive and impractical but as
time passed competitors entered the
market and of course these competitors
were able to offer their parts at much
cheaper prices probably because they
have spent nearly as much on research
and development it also didn't have to
advertise very much as segway had
already introduced a market did this
type of product furthermore other
companies were bringing out other
business models that offered similar
technology for instance lime brought
electric scooters to major cities for a
very small writing fee of just a couple
of dollars per ride for people who
didn't use these very often this made
much more sense in buying their own
Segway or electric scooter and finally
to top it all off there were so many
news articles about segways causing
injury whether it was a rider's fault or
the devices fault this seriously
increased caution among potential buyers
and lower the chance of them actually
following through with the purchase but
despite all of these fatal issues Segway
did grow in popularity you could often
go outside in big cities and see people
riding segways as if it really were an
alternative to walking the issue here
however was that people weren't buying
segways as an alternative to walking as
a company intended instead people bought
segways because of the novelty of the
product come on now you can't argue that
segways aren't just plain coal the
technology in segways was something that
we had never witnessed before you could
simply shift your center of mass forward
or back to move forward or back and you
can control the speed as well based on
how much you leaned and this innovation
is what really drove sales for Segway
during the second rise in 2015 people
were curious to try them out for
themselves and countless bills on
YouTube using segways just led to even
more curiosity
however eventually you or someone you
know probably gave in to his curiosity
and got a segue and you got a chance to
try it
it was probably fun as he got a hang of
it for the first time if you bought it
you might have taken it with you as a
travel through the city or show your
friends but sooner or later the novelty
wears out and this is where practicality
should kick in but the problem is that
there is not much practicality it's
heavy expensive and only works on smooth
platforms and that was the problem
Segway was able to grow an attraction
using her intriguing technology but as
they never solved an itch problem for
any group of people as a novelty died
out so did Segway if they had really
pursued one field like mall security or
the USPS and really made a positive
impact on the efficiency of the people
working these jobs Segway may have had a
chance
however targeting the general people was
simply unsustainable as a clear issue
was not being solved for them and this
led to their eventual demise but that's
just what I think
did you guys get a Segway if so what do
you think about it make sure to comment
that down below also if you guys liked
the video then make sure to put like and
consider subscribing if I see more
questions like this one and
psychologically bonne till then I'm Mari
I'll see you guys on the next one